bonjour je suis ravi d'être avec vous
aujourd'hui pour discuter de la question
de la diversité des technologies
numériques et de notre position
européenne
le constat malheureusement c'est que
l'innovation en europe décline et nous
sommes à la traîne de ce qui se passe
aux etats-unis et en chine et nous
finissons par utiliser des technologies
monolithique pas forcément adaptée à nos
besoins
ou alors non alignés sur nos valeurs or
on se rend compte
d'autant plus depuis le début de la
crise liée aux coronavirus que les
technologies numériques sont essentiels
pour maintenir la vie économique et
social ces technologies numériques comme
vous le voyez là ont envahi tous les
aspects de notre vie quotidienne
on peut parler de la visioconférence des
environnements de travail collaboratif
ou des systèmes de jeu multijoueur
massif des systèmes de recommandation
par exemple de vidéo ou les réseaux
sociaux
et puis c'est bien sûr aussi le cas pour
des domaines plus traditionnels tels que
la santé l'éducation l'industrie
les technologies sont partout et sont
indispensables et quand je dis que ces
technologies numériques dont nous
disposons sont monolithique et qu'elles
ne correspondent pas forcément à nos
besoins
je peux citer par exemple les personnels
de soignants les personnels soignants de
ville 1 qui se sont trouvés complètement
démunis pendant la pandémie
malgré tout les outils qui sont à leur
disposition donc à 3 par exemple ils
m'ont raconté qu'il avait besoin pendant
sept mois et demi de coopérer avec des
équipes qui changeait tout le temps
rapidement que ça soit simple et tout ça
c'était pas pris en charge par les
outils actuels et ils ont fini pour
beaucoup d'entre eux par utiliser
whatsapp ce qui pour le coup en terme de
protection des données et de
confidentialité est loin d'être l'idéal
il ya aussi eu pendant cette pandémie
des plateformes mises en place pour
organiser toutes les initiatives
un des exemples les plus marquants que
j'ai vu et dont on m'a parlé c'est celui
conduit à timisoara en roumanie là-bas
en fait un groupe de volontaires et des
ong ont créé la plateforme que vous
voyez là antico vite et m elle a permis
de rendre visibles toutes les
initiatives qui apporté de l'aide sous
toutes ses formes pendant la pandémie en
particulier pour les personnes âgées
donc en fait elle
en relation les volontaires qui
souhaitaient participer et elle a aidé
les initiatives à se coordonner et elle
a permis aux gens qu'ils avaient besoin
dead 2 d'en demander par ailleurs quand
je dis que nous utilisons des
technologies monolithique qui sont pas
forcément aligné sur nos valeurs
en fait je pense en particulier au
nombre de plus en plus important de
communautés locales d'associations qui
agissent au sein des quartiers des
villages et qui cherchent à avoir un
impact positif sur la société en
redynamisant des quartiers en créant des
emplois en évitant le gaspillage en
privilégiant les circuits courts entre
producteurs et consommateurs est en fait
de plus en plus c'est collectif ils se
sont rendus compte du rôle que les
technologies numériques peuvent jouer
dans leurs activités pour les rendre
visibles ou les coordonnées comme on a
déjà vu l'exemple que vous voyez ici
c'est celui du village de germaine dans
la marne et dans ce village il y à une
association qui s'élançait qui s'appelle
le cerf à trois pattes et c'est à la
fois un collectif d'habitants qui se
réunissent des activités collectives qui
sont menées et aussi une épicerie locale
et solidaire et enfin bien sûr des
technologies numériques pour se tenir au
courant des activités qui sont menées et
commander des produits locaux et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que pendant la
pandémie
ces technologies numériques elles ont
pris une place énorme
elles ont permis à tous les habitants de
germaine et autour qui pouvaient plus
déplacée de bénéficier des services du
cerf à trois pattes et une solidarité
s'est mise en place pour aller livrer
les courses au plus âgé est en fait
pendant la pandémie les ventes ont
décollé le chiffre d'affaires de
l'association a explosé et ça va
permettre à cette association de lancer
de nouveaux projets d'aménagement au
sein du village
il ya de nombreux projets comme ça
positifs partout dans le monde
entre des chercheurs etc collectif en
particulier dans le domaine que je viens
de citer la qui le domaine de
l'alimentation qui ont permis
d'améliorer par exemple des stratégies
d'achats de produits biologiques ou qui
ont permis de soutenir la lutte contre
le gaspillage alimentaire est en fait
qu'ils arrivent souvent un point de
discussion qui émerge régulièrement
entre ces chercheurs etc collectif c'est
que ce qui est difficile c'est de
trouver des technologies numériques qui
sont alignés sur les valeurs de ces
collectifs en fait finalement comment
est-ce que d'une part
on peut militer contre le gaspillage la
consommation à outrance et puis d'autre
part finir par utiliser des plateformes
numériques que je citerai pas mais
produite par la silicon valley qui sont
à mille lieues de ses valeurs et ses
plateformes s'intéresse a finalement
utilisé les données et les revendre et
il y a déjà eu des résultats
intéressants de propositions de plates
formes numériques originales comme par
exemple l'initiative des logiciels open
source pour gérer les exploitations
agricoles comme ce que vous voyez là
farm os ou des ressources mises en
commun par le réseau open food mais on
peut aller plus loin encore dans cette
relation entre la conception de
technologies numériques en accord avec
les valeurs des citoyens pour y arriver
en fait les des initiatives politiques
comme la démarche européenne en matière
de transformation numérique
c'est essentiel et pour reprendre les
mots de thierry breton qui est quand
même il faut le rappeler le premier
président du conseil d'administration de
lutte était et qui est depuis le 1er
décembre 2019
le commissaire européen au marché
intérieur en charge en particulier de
renforcer la souveraineté technologique
de l'europe l'europe en tant que
continent doit faire en sorte que ses
citoyens et ses entreprises aient accès
à un éventail de technologies dernier
cri qui rendront leur vie meilleure plus
sûr et même plus écologique
à condition qu'ils disposent aussi des
compétences pour les utiliser c'est
ainsi que nous façonneront ensemble une
europe résiliente et souveraine
sur le plan numérique dont le monde post
pandémie c'est cela la décennie
numérique de l'europe
et ça c'est un discours du 9 mars 2021
ce discours il s'intègre en fait dont la
stratégie de transformation numérique
qui a été dévoilée par la commission
européenne en février 2020 dans cette
stratégie
la commission a indiqué ces idées et ces
mesures pour une transformation
numérique profitable à tous reflétant le
meilleur de ce que l'europe offre
c'est-à-dire l'ouverture l'équité la
diversité la démocratie
et bien sûr la confiance cette stratégie
en fait elle présente une société
européenne qui serait soutenu par des
solutions numériques mais des solutions
numériques pas n'importe lesquels des
solutions qui place les citoyens au
premier plan qui ouvre de nouvelles
perspectives aux entreprises mais aussi
qui encourage le développement de
technologies fiables et tout ça pour
quoi
pour promouvoir une société ouverte et
démocratique et une économie dynamique
et durable
alors la question finalement c'est que
l'europe
elle souhaite en tirer parti de sa
longue histoire en termes de technologie
de recherche d'innovation et
d'ingéniosité et de sa solide protection
des droits et des valeurs fondamentales
des citoyens
mais comment arriver à faire cela et
bien finalement ce que je vous propose
c'est de réfléchir à la façon de mener à
bien cette transformation numérique qui
valorise les interactions sociales comme
un bien commun plutôt que comme une
source de revenus et d'accumulation
comme on le voit donc d'autres
plateformes que j'ai indiquées
précédemment
et ainsi on sera en mesure de proposer
une diversité des technologies
numériques adaptés à des solutions
variées et aligné sur les valeurs de
l'europe
en fait il s'agit là d'une réflexion
radical en informatique il s'agit de ne
plus se focaliser uniquement sur les
aspects matériels et logiciels de
l'informatique mais de prendre en compte
le contexte dans lequel les technologies
numériques sont utilisées donc prendre
en compte les enjeux humains les gens
dieu sociaux les enjeux organisationnels
quand on conçoit ses technologies donc
finalement dit autrement il s'agit de
passer d'une approche purement
techniques de l'informatique à une
approche qui considère les activités
humaines comme étant une préoccupation
centrale quand on veut concevoir les
technologies numériques
et donc ce que je défends ici finalement
c'est que si on veut relever ce défi
d'une ambition technologique pour
l'europe il faut se doter d'une approche
de conception des technologies
numériques qui soient centrées sur les
pratiques et vous fait cette approche de
conception elle existe elle existe
depuis plus de 30 ans elle a été
constituée par les chercheurs d'un
domaine qui s'appelle en anglais le sida
blue conclure je supporte petite
coopérative work ou en français travail
coopératif assistée par ordinateur et ce
domaine
il a émergé en fait simultanément au
milieu des années 80 dans des centres de
recherche en europe et dans des centres
de recherche aux états unis
essentiellement des centres de recherche
industrielle comme xerox et ibm puis
ensuite microsoft et il ya dix ans
maintenant avec un ensemble de
chercheurs et d'entreprises basées en
europe
nous avons décidé de rendre ce domaine
plus visible en europe parce qu'il nous
semblait pas assez visibles et on a
décidé de le rendre plus visible auprès
des étudiants des chercheurs des
entreprises et aussi des institutions
européennes en créant l'association
européenne
enfin on pourrait dire internationale
mais basées en europe ue 7 et on a été
rejoint dans cette association par un
grand nombre de chercheurs du monde
entier pour le coup qui partage cette
approche centrée sur les pratiques et
nous sommes actuellement plus de 300
youth est ça signifie european society
of the cherry en belgique technologies
donc si on traduit c'est la société
européenne des technologies socialement
intégré donc intégré dans les pratiques
sociales
mais alors qu'est ce que signifie
finalement cette idée de conception sont
créés sur les pratiques ou de
technologies intégrées dans les
pratiques sociales
en fait ça représente l'idée que les
technologies numériques
elles n'ont pas une fin en soi mais elle
il faut les voir plutôt comme une
infrastructure pour le développement des
pratiques sociales et en fait l'idée
c'est qu'on ne peut pas séparer
l'analyse de ces pratiques sociales de
l'analyse finalement et de la conception
des technologies qui vont accompagner
ces pratiques
c'est ce qu'on appelle adopter une
approche socio technique est en fête
on adopte une telle approche socio
techniques en informatique
finalement les critères de conception
traditionnelle en informatique comme la
performance la justesse la robustesse ou
la facilité d'utilisation elles
suffisent plus il faut compléter ces
critères par des méthodes et des
perspectives qui vont éclairer la façon
dont la technologie et la pratique vont
se développer
finalement mutuellement dans une
approche socio technique
on conçoit bien sûr évidemment des
dispositifs qui sont basées sur des
innovations informatiques qui sont de
haute qualité technique mais en fait le
paradigme de recherche
il est complètement différent l'accent
particulier qui est mis sur les
pratiques sociales
ils exigent de comprendre les
caractéristiques sociales du contexte
dans lequel ces outils numériques
ils vont être intégrés et bien sûr ça
devient de plus en plus important parce
que comme on en parlait tout à l'heure
ses outils imprègne notre vie
quotidienne c'est à dire qu'ils sont
plus utilisés seulement dans le cadre du
travail est en fait ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que les méthodes les résultats et
les concepts qui sont produits par des
chercheurs en sciences sociales cette
fois ci ils ont beaucoup contribué
depuis 30 à la recherche socio technique
mais l'objectif de ces travaux en
sciences sociales il est de décrire et
de comprendre des phénomènes d
collective des activités mais pas
forcément de concevoir des outils
numériques
donc l'objectif de la conception centrée
sur les pratiques c'est d'utiliser ces
compréhension pour la conception des
outils informatiques ainsi des
technologies numériques qui serait
centrée sur les pratiques elles
pourraient à la fois améliorer
considérablement la qualité des
interactions sociales mais aussi plus
globalement l'efficacité de l'action
humaine donc dit autrement
nous avons besoin d'une compréhension
riches du monde pour arriver à concevoir
des technologies numériques que les gens
trouvent utile utilisable conforma les
valeurs à leur valeur et qu'ils
respecteraient leurs droits pourtant ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que plus de 30 ans
après ses premières recherches sur la
conception centrée sur les pratiques ou
sur les approches sociaux techniques ont
continué finalement avoir un écart
énorme entre d'un côté
des développements qui serait purement
technique et de l'autre des études qui
vont aller regarder l'impact de l'usagé
de ces technologies
or en fait c'est entre les deux qu'il
faut travailler c'est à dire qu'il faut
s'engager dans la conception et le
développement innovant de technologies
numériques mais qui intégrerait la
compréhension des activités
individuelles et sociales et cette
pluridisciplinarité finalement c'est la
seule façon de tirer parti des capacités
humaines et sociales et de les augmenter
avec des nouvelles technologies
numériques
donc finalement ce que je dirais c'est
qu'en europe nous avons une forte
tradition de recherche philosophique
sociologique et anthropologique
elle nous permet de comprendre le monde
et cette compréhension fine elle devrait
donc pouvoir apporter une contribution
significative à l'articulation de
scénario plus réaliste dans la
conception que ce qui serait dérivé
uniquement dans un espèce de fétichisme
technologique
donc nous devons nous appuyer sur cette
compréhension plutôt que de l'ignorer
faire comme si ça n'avait rien à voir
avec les technologies c'est pourquoi je
plaide aujourd'hui avec ce que l'on fait
aussi dans l'association youth est en
faveur d'un nouveau paradigme de
recherche au sein de l'union européenne
pour mener à bien sa transformation
numérique c'est-à-dire une exploration
des technologies numériques centrés sur
les pratiques pour la société européenne
du 21e siècle
merci